You are watching Cold Fusion TV
Hi, welcome to another Cold Fusion video.
It seems that things are once again moving
faster than anticipated with alternative
energy technology.  Wind and solar power
are great, but the main issue with these
forms of power generation was storing
energy for later use. Until now.
Tesla Energy and Elon Musk have been making
headlines in recent weeks.  Due to pulling
off feats that many analysts thought
would be years away. In this video we'll
take a look at what's been going on in.
In early March Tesla energy turned on the
switch for a huge solar farm and energy
storage facility that will help power the
Hawaiian island of Kauai. In Hawaii, the
electric car maker Tesla is powering up
its plans for energy storage in fact
it's industrial battery packs are now
helping a utility in Hawaii generate
enough electricity for an entire island.
We're able to show that we can directly
absorb solar power throughout the day
into these batteries and then discharge
it back at night and stabilize it even
though we might have clouds coming over
or even though it might not line up
directly with when people want to use
the energy.  This can solve that problem.
for those of you here into the facts the
Kauai island is where the Lilo and
Stitch movies took place and is also
featured in over 70 Hollywood films
anyway Tesla's farm is the first
utility-scale solar energy system in the
United States that can meet electricity
demand even at night. It's one of the
biggest battery systems on the planet
The project has 55,000 solar panels and
272 Tesla Power Packs these can provide
52 megawatt hours of storage and will
provide 13 megawatts of power for the
grid. So why Hawaii? Apart from being a
sunny location Hawaii has no pipelines
running to it so to get power currently
barrels with fuel have to be shipped in
this makes oil expensive for the island
the idea is that with solar and battery
storage they will have  to ship in less oil
meaning that they
save money the company in charge of the
islands energy utilities will purchase
power from Tesla's farm at a set cost of
thirteen point nine cents per kilowatt
hour this is less than the current cost
of oil for Hawaii Tesla energy isn't just
starting work in Hawaii though in Southern
California 396 Tesla batteries have been
installed to suck up excess electricity
from the grid during the day and feed it
back into the grid as needed especially
at night these batteries to charge our
phones flashlights and run all kinds of
electronic gadgets right how about
powering up your homes these large light
boxes don't look like much but Southern
California Edison says they could change
the way home owners get their energy in
the future it's technology that wasn't
there before and we're now ready to
deploy it where it's needed locations
where it works the Tesla battery system
which can power 1500 homes for more than
four hours was actually part of an
emergency response the emergency arose
because it was projected that California
will have energy shortages due to a
leak at a natural gas storage facility
in California aging nuclear plants have
been closed or phased out putting even
more pressure on utilities to find other
ways to feed the grid utility executives
say that energy storage is the natural
solution the California battery plant
came online in late January so this
event may not seem like much to many
people out there but this feat serves as
a powerful precedent it shows the
utilities can actually use battery
systems to replace conventional power
plants this recent progress has even
taken seasoned professionals by complete
surprise Michael J Picker president of
the California Public Utilities
Commission in response to the Tesla
system States quote I had relatively
limited expectations for the battery
industry before 2020 I thought that it
would not really accelerate and begin to
penetrate the electric grid or
transportation world for a while to come
once again technology is clearly moving
faster than we can regulate end quote
the whole battery system was
manufactured by Tesla shipped installed
and ready for operation in three months
all the batteries cooling safety systems
and other equipment are packed inside
the casings ready to load onto delivery
trucks it's almost a plug-and-play
system the lithium battery packs come
from Tesla's gigafactory in Nevada the
factory is able to set a hundred Boeing
747 and is one of the biggest buildings
on earth the gigafactory will soon also
make Tesla energy the single biggest
battery manufacturer on earth the large
economy of scale makes all the
difference here it's the reason why this
kind of thing can be done now and hasn't
been done before many would argue that
producing all of these batteries is
damaging to the environment but of
course this issue has already been taken
into consideration the batteries are
recycled by Tesla once they've been
decommissioned right now new batteries
are built from raw materials that come
in via rail straight into the factory
for optimum efficiency and minimal waste
in other words is pretty much a closed
manufacturing system the mother of all
vertical integration structures another
cool thing about the Tesla power pack is
that they're extremely scalable so you
could buy one to power your business or
hook up a few hundred to run an island
or even a state Tesla energy will expand
operations into other areas of
California America and even overseas one
such place that's been proposed is South
Australia so why South Australia well in
September 2016 South Australia suffered
a statewide blackout as infrastructure
was damaged during a storm good evening
the cause of a blackout which plunged
more than a hundred thousand South
Australian homes and businesses into
darkness remains a mystery not suddenly
becoming even darker at ten-thirty last
night 110,000 homes and businesses were
blacked out until the early hours
traffic lights dangerously dimmed from
above we were a city divided in two well
that was just faster than looking
straight and even a shopping center
everything's gone we're not sure exactly
sure we know hot when you know what
happened because not sure why 150
megawatts of power was being supplied
from Victoria last night concerns now
just how much of an impact the loss of
Port Augusta a Lynx a power station will
have when it closes by March recently
there was
another blackout due to a heat wave
because there wasn't enough power to
meet demand Elon Musk proposed that he
could fix South Australia's power issues
by installing an 80 megawatt hour power
pack like he did in Southern California
the bill is as follows the energy
problem will be solved to the Tesla
battery system within a hundred days if
this doesn't happen South Australia gets
the system for free musk himself has a
big vision for stationary energy storage
he states that quote if something I
think we'll probably be as big as the
car business long term it will actually
have a growth rate probably several
times that of what the car business is
per year the growth in stationary
storage is really underappreciated it's
a super exponential growth rate and
quote ok so this all sounds well and
good but before we get too carried away
there are still some important questions
that need to be answered for example how
much exactly do these systems cost no
director figures have been given that
being said whatever the cost is it
should reduce overtime as production
ramped up secondly what is the ultimate
life of the battery packs in real-world
scenarios again we're not sure in
conclusion environmentally sustainable
battery systems like Tesla's power packs
are a great solution to solve the
intermittent nature of solar and wind
energy although maybe still a little
early to tell this concept does seem
promising story access power and
delivering at when needed will become an
integral part of the world shift to
renewable energy anyway I hope that you
enjoyed this video on some of the
cutting-edge stuff that's going on the
Tesla energy from around the world in a
general way things really seem to be
moving there's pretty cool to live in a
time with great shift in the status quo
it can be so clearly witnessed thanks for
watching guys don't forget to subscribe
to this channel if you just stumbled
across it this has been to go go you've
been watching cold fusion and I'll catch
you again soon for the next video cheers
guys have a good one
coldfusion it's new thinking